i've given you these questions as i
always do to try and warm up your brains
for things that will be relevant for
this lesson so you may able may be able
to fill this in i always like to give
spoiler-free headings i hate i don't
know if anyone's like a marvel movie fan
but like i really wanted to enjoy
spider-man no way home with no spoilers
and it's very difficult and it made a
big difference in my experience of the
movie so that's why i've left that blank
but you'll probably be able to guess
based on what we're looking at here
let's start with one and two we've got
this log base e of 20. now quick
question for you right you've got an
answer here
2.996 by the way some agreement you're
happy with that yeah thumbs up okay now
remember what does it mean what is the
significance of this number the idea is
logs tell you what power should you
raise to to get a certain result right
from a certain base remember this is
like 2.7
or so
what power do you raise that to
to get to 20. that's all this is asking
right so this is like
2.996 so this is something like three
raised to a power a little bit less than
three so we know that three cubed is
it's 27. so you can see even though it's
actually quite close to three that teeny
little bit of difference makes quite a
bit of a gap to this number over here
but we know we're in the ballpark does
that make sense
okay now having a question two and i saw
um daniel was it you who put the answer
up yeah um it's the same what's going on
here there's actually a log
law that i'm trying to get you to
remember by seeing these numbers can
anyone state the law for me
what do you reckon i know daniel you
know because you put him up did someone
else know there's someone you can even
see it from the board any
suggestions yeah go ahead
log
a plus log b equals 8 again
log a b so it's this weird thing where
when you for example add logs together
effectively what you're doing is you're
multiplying those two things in the log
so that's why 4 times 5 gives you 20.
same deal does that make sense so in
fact if you knew your log laws as soon
as you got this you you realize you had
that as well okay
all right i'm quite happy with three and
four i just gave some exact ones in
there for you so it wasn't all just
calculated work i want you to think
about the meanings of these logs not
just be able to punch buttons okay now
just have a look at this last one for me
again there's a log law hiding
underneath here that i wonder if you
guys recognize it's related to this one
but it's not the same what's the log
ball you can see daniel
okay fantastic so when you've got a
minus sign here this doesn't become
multiplication it's the opposite of that
which is division okay now this is just
a sneaky curveball i threw right in here
because this here
as you can see the log law stated it's
not exactly the same like see how these
are identical but these are not what's
the difference
yeah it's it's it's the reciprocal yeah
so there's actually one final log law
which i'd love you all to jot down with
me that's related to these two but it
kind of gets it this one in here right
see that minus sign that minus sign
this you can rewrite as
log
base 10
one breath two-fifths to the power of
negative one do you see that right it's
still a fraction but i've flipped it
upside down with this negative index now
if you recall and you saw it here in
this example one of the things you can
do with logs is that index up there
it can sort of jump out the front like
so so it's the same as minus
log
base 10 of two-fifths which you already
worked out so that's why this is the
minus of or the negative rather of this
you see why they're the same magnitude
but opposite in sign you okay with that
all right fantastic
so you can rule that off and like i said
not that many prizes for guessing what
the missing word is in today's heading
it's differentiating
logarithmic functions okay now
i've said this enough times even in our
few lessons together that hopefully you
can repeat it back to me right why might
we be looking at logarithms when we have
just spent a whole bunch of lessons
talking about exponentials what's the
connection between them
yeah go ahead
it's it's the same deal just like looked
at the in reverse it's why you've got
like multiplication and division
right they're opposites to each other so
that's why it's a very natural next step
to go to these based on our time with
exponentials okay
so here's what i want us to think about
and maybe you can draw underneath here
for me a couple of axes that we can draw
a graph on okay they don't have to be
massive there won't be a lot of detail
on them but the first one is going to
look like this
and then the second one's going to look
like
this you're used to having a cartesian
plane that's got all the quadrants on it
but we're just going to draw the top
half of the graph for this one
and the right hand half of the graph
for this one and you'll see why in a
second
to understand differentiating
logarithmic functions i want to take you
back to the first time it was last year
right so that's why i'm trying to review
this that you are differentiating
exponential functions right now on your
first graph and this is why it's just
the top half right on your first graph
i'd love you to draw me a nice rough and
ready exponential function okay so it
should look
something like that okay
now
on this exponential function i haven't
told you which exponential function is
it could be e to the x 2 to the x 3 d x
doesn't really matter
what i want you to think about is what
does the picture what does the graph
tell you
about the derivative of that graph
what i'm trying to get here this is so
important actually i'm going to write it
down what i'm trying to get at here is
that when you differentiate something
this is not just where we're going to
fit it here we'll do
it's not just an algebraic
or a symbolic
process it's not just like rearranging
the algebra and the different symbols so
you get another answer out
differentiation is also it's a visual
process or you can think of it as a
geometric process if you look at the
shape of something you can understand
its derivative so have a look what can
you tell me i know you know what the
answer is but tell me something about
the derivative of this graph some
quality not not like symbols tell me
some feature that it has daniel you've
given me so many good answers today i'm
gonna hit pause on you thank you someone
else want to throw in an idea
can anyone tell me yes
what do you mean by it's a tangent what
are you getting at
okay so i can draw any point along here
right i could pick a point like say here
and i can draw a tangent yeah now i want
to focus on this idea right no matter
which tangent i draw pick a point here
in fact maybe you want to put some of
these tangents on with me right
pick a spot like that one i'm guessing
the tangent looks like that
draw another tangent on any way you like
have it here we don't want to crowd them
out too much i reckon i've got enough
space on my diagram to fit one more
chuck one right up there
all of these tangents share something in
common
do you see
even though they're differing amounts
every one is increasing in gradient do
you see that they're all going upwards
and what that corresponds to is that
this graph let's call it e to the x it's
always increasing always increasing
right
from left to right the bigger you go the
steeper it gets okay
in other words this is what tells us
i need another color and this is what
tells us
that the gradient function of this
exponential
is very much like an exponential itself
like so
the gradient starts off really small do
you see that it's really shallow over
here and then it just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger just like an
exponential okay so this is what's
happening here i want you to now think
about can we apply similar logic
for one of these okay now before you
draw it can you just like motion with
your hands this is what an exponential
function looks like you could like do
the curve in the air right can you do
that for me i just want to get a read of
how familiar you guys are with a
logarithmic function can you do one in
the air in front if you want to see what
kind of shape you're tracing out
yeah okay not bad all right fantastic
can you draw one on this right hand
graph for me
exponentials the logs are really nice to
draw you're just like wee off okay and
it's pretty good right
now i want to ask this same question
that we asked of this geometrically the
exponential i want to ask it about the
log what can you tell me
about the gradient
of that function yeah go ahead
okay so there's definitely like there's
a clear relationship between these right
and we do call them inverses so this
thing is going to have something to do
with this so i'm going to park that
thought because we're going to come
right back to it richard do you want to
give me another thought
the gradient say that one more time just
so everyone can catch it
the gradient is constantly decreasing
now that's so important i think actually
we should write it and i'm going to
illustrate it with um the same way we
did before so the gradient drop this
down with me
is constantly
decreasing
now i'm just going to put um put the
word constantly in quote marks for me
because um in maths you guys know
sometimes words have very technical
meanings right the word constant means
something very specific in maths that i
think i see what you're getting at but
it's like
sort of i wonder if you guys can help me
in a second to work out a more
technically accurate word but i like the
idea let's have a look
if i pull the same trick i did seb
suggested we look at some tangents right
i'm going to do the same thing over here
draw some tangents with me right so
here's a tangent it's something like
that
and you're happy that looks okay you can
do a better job using a ruler here's
another tangent
and i'll fit one more
okay
now rishi's comment about the gradient
decreasing is that this is like steep
this is kind of like medium i guess
and this is quite shallow so this tells
you the gradient's getting less and less
and less
is the gradient ever negative
what would a gradient that's negative
actually look like on the graph it would
have to start going
down wouldn't it right which on this
graph would be the sort of equivalent of
like curling back on itself it's not
going to ever do that right so it's
constantly decreasing and the other
thing we note is
it's always positive
oops
now i'm not talking about the graph
itself look this part of the graph is
negative i'm talking about the gradient
of the graph it's always positive maybe
i should write that gradient
so
i'm going to give you a second to think
about this right on your page
just like see how i drew this red graph
where i'm like oh that one
is the gradient
[Music]
i'd like you if you don't have enough
color that's okay just use whatever you
have available
just in the same way that i put the
graph and its gradient together
with this graph can you also put what
you think the gradient looks like on top
of this so both graphs sort of coexist a
bit like this okay some of you might
know the answer already good for you but
for the rest of us i'm trying to develop
your visual intuition before we prove it
with the symbols can you take a second
to do that and i'll come around and have
a quick look